precisely with the person close to you
that in a way the gap between any two
human consciousnesses becomes most
[Music]
[Applause]
apparent dostoevski and nature both
regarded the creeping nihilism and
meaninglessness of their time as a
fundamental threat to humanity while
both were critical of modernity and
rationalism their Solutions were
radically opposed
doovi looked towards Transcendence for
an answer and found in love and
compassion the chief law of human
existence while n declared God dead and
found meaning in human nature and the
assertion of human
creativity is dovi as some have argued a
denial of all that is human and an
acceptance of authority and oppression
or is it nature who is most dangerous in
his endorsement of human desire and the
will to power can meaning only be found
found outside of ourselves in the love
of others and in God's love for us or
should we follow nature and see human
will and desire as the means to create
meaning we have a fantastic panel for
you today Oliver ready is a celebrated
translator and literary scholar his
translation of dov's Crime and
Punishment has received critical
Acclaim readyy teaches Russian
literature and translation at St Edwin's
Hall
Oxford Kathleen Higgins is a leading and
wide- ranging philosopher at the
University of Texas Austin her
specialities are Broad and include the
philosophy of Aesthetics emotion and
music author of many acclaimed books on
nature janer is a critically acclaimed
writer whose novels include Odin's
Island and come also nothing an
existential novel about the question of
nihilism an award-winning book that has
been translated into 36
languages so we'll start with our
opening question and each speakers will
give a three minute
pitch is the answer to nihilism and
meaninglessness in n's vision of human
nature or is it in dov's love and
compassion Kathleen do you want to start
us off sure um I would say that
certainly love provides meaning in life
did n think that it depends on what you
mean by love I think he did think that
the kinds of things that would provide
meaning in life all involve love of some
sort but he was more skeptical about
compassion certainly as compassion was
preached to people as he thought love of
neighbor what he grown up with as the
ideal amounted to the difficulty he saw
with compassion is that it's a very
receptive point of view he was far from
someone who didn't think that was good
in fact he himself tried to to analyze
different kinds of characters in
something like a literary way so that
people would be able to empathize with
them from their own point of view and I
think that is actually attempting to
inspire compassion in his audience but
he tended to think that compassion as a
project wouldn't work partly because
compassion as a project is so UNS
situated in general um it amounts to
from his point of view something like
you know you go first no you um there's
there's not really any impetus behind it
whereas I think he thought inevitably
given our willful Natures what was
essential to finding meaning and a
satisfactory way in our existence is
going to be really throwing ourselves
into some project um even if that
project is a kind of aspiration to be a
certain kind of person he thought that's
the kind of thing that everybody
actually benefits from if only because
people end up feeling a lot more um
embraced or um a lot more supported by
people who feel a certain kind of sense
of themselves uh so I think that um n
has a has a point in all of these claims
and U I'll probably say more about that
as we go thank
you right so I think I've been set up
here to represent d
which I'm broadly speaking happy to do
I'm not an uncritical admirer um so I
think I begin just by trying to pin down
this Association of DVI with love and
compassion um many I think Russians
would be surprised by that description
tul sty said after D's death that he was
quote all struggle always fighting with
himself and um Tolstoy knew about that
too uh many ukrainians and not just
ukrainians would be I think seriously
object to uh the idea of a loving
compassionate DVI the man who at the
height of his Fame and influence in the
1870s wrote many articles dripping with
hatred for other nations faiths other
confessions all in the name of uh
supposedly Christian love that that
would be headed spearheaded by Russia as
first among equals and we see how that's
playing out right now with the blessing
of both SAR and
patriarch uh it's interesting that n who
as you say rejects compassion also
rejected nationalism dovi who's whose
novels um abound in scenes of compassion
Embraces ends up embracing
nationalism that's the journalism and if
we turn to the novels the fiction which
is what most of us will value dovi for
we see there that like the journalism
the the novels are also rooted in faith
in Christian faith in questions of Faith
but in a much more genuinely Universal
way that clearly has appealed to both
Believers and non-believers alike um
he's inspired evidently and by the the
imperative which is not purely Christian
of course but common to all religions
love your neighbor as yourself but he
probes it uh and his novels ask is it
even possible to love your neighbor as
yourself not just that is it even
possible to um to understand another
person um and uh in fact in the Russian
translation of the of the New Testament
Neighbor comes out as the person close
to you and and and all of the's novels
are based on you know how you interact
with the person close to you in your own
room the person in the room with you in
your own home in your own marriage um
because it's precisely with the person
close to you that in a way the gap
between any two human consciousnesses
becomes most apparent and so you know
that we may not understand the person we
live our life with or whatever it can
become a kind of abyss of
meaninglessness and that's the challenge
that Doki faces fais and tries to
confront as a novelist how do you create
meaning by looking at this kind of very
nuclear inter human interaction how do
you create meaningful dialogue uh and
here again we have the crucial control
with n who rejects love of the neighbor
and instead correct me if I'm wrong
Kathleen promotes the idea of Love of
the
distant yeah we can explore this further
but the dividing line there is the
question of compassion but dvi's
compassion is not perhaps what we would
commonly understand by compassion and
I'd like to come back to that later to
explore that
um yes if this was about science we
would be able to test who is Right n
Doki unfortunately isn't like that so as
a novelist I'll come in more like with a
a
story um because I don't think any of
them is right nor are they totally wrong
but if we uh say why are we here because
you have to come back to that very basic
question to even start thinking about
who is more right and there's that
there's no nobody has that answer why
are we here we we don't know if there is
a God or which God it would be uh or if
there's none we can only when it comes
down to it believe even atheism is a
form of belief um and when we can't know
why we are here yes then you can say
everything is
meaningless and
um I wrote in a book that
questions or or that puts that question
in the mouth of a 14-year-old boy and
his friends then sets out to prove to
him life matters because he say things
like the Earth is 4.6 billion years old
and you live maximum to about 100 life
isn't worth the B and other similar
things um and when you question life in
that large
perspective it does become very
meaningless to be a human being being
you know here or at any time and at the
same time the thing is we do live in the
here and now we don't live in that large
perspective so one can also turn it
around and say the Here and Now
everything matters so I don't think it's
a choice
between love and compassion or just
willful powerful in competition with
your peers we as human beings yes we are
competitive uh and we fight but we can
make love and compassion give
meaning but very the very existance
since we are born and we have this gift
of life it's pretty amazing actually we
can stretch and bend our hands we can
feel some even when we are sad or bored
it's quite fantastic you can feel sad or
bored where does it come from and so we
have this absolutely amazing gift of
life for a certain number of years we
have no clue where it comes from but
maybe that makes that gift so much more
valuable and then we can use that gift
in many different ways to give it the
meaning that we want our life to have
and there one can yet choose one or the
other approach but I believe life itself
simply since we have it has a
meaning thank you we're now really going
to get to the heart of the debate um and
I'm going to put this to Oliver first um
feel free to answer generally or on
behalf of Doki as you are are the
appointed spokesperson in this debate
can meaning only be found outside of
ourselves to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or Visit ii. TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas